اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسمو المعالي
يلتئم هذا الجمال الكريم للمره الثانيه
بعد قمتنا الاولى التي احتضنتها بغداد في
اغسطس عام 2021
اين تعدنا معا الى دعم الجهود الوطنيه
لاشقائنا في العراق حكومه وشعبا في سبيل
تحقيق امن واستقرار بلادهم وحفظ سيادتها
واستعاده مكانتها
التاريخيه ودورها العربي والاقليمي الفاعل
اجتماعنا اليوم ونحن نشهد تحسنا الملحوظا
في الاوضاع في العراق
واغتنم هذه المناسبه لكي اتقدم بخالص
التهنئه الى دوله رئيس الوزراء العراقي
محمد شياع السوداني وللشعب العراقي العزيز
على استكمال مراحل الاستحقاق الدستوريه
وبما يفتح المجال للانطلاق نحو المستقبل
سياده الحضور
انعقاد قمتنا اليوم يحمل معه دلاله سياسيه
مهمه على اعتزامينا مواصلات توفير كافه
سبل الدعم للعراق الشقيق
ورغبه صادقه في الانتقال الى مرحله جديده
من الشراكه من خلال تعزيز العمل في قطر
التعاون الثنائي او المتعدد كليه التعاون
الثلاثي بين مصر والعراق والاردن او غيرها
كما يمثل اجتماعنا الفرصه لتبادل وجهات
النظر
واستكشاف جديده للتنسيق والتعاون بين
بلادنا والعراق
نعم لمسيرته نحو الاستقرار
وبما يعزز قدراتنا في مواجهه التحديات
المرتبطه بالازمات الدوليه وما يستتبعها
من تحديات عابره للحدود في مجالات الصحه
وامن الغذاء والطاقه وسلاسل الامداد
وغيرها وبما يحقق مصالح شعوبنا
لقد واجه العراق على مدار سنوات طويله
انعكاسات بالغه السلبيه لانتشار الارهاب
والفكر المتطرف وولات الصراعات والحروب
طويله الامل
السياق لم يخلق من تدخلات خارجيه على نحو
اثقل كاهل العراقيين وارتدت اثاره الى كل
شعوب المنطقه
وتسمى مصر غاليا
في هذا الصدد الجهود والتضحيات
التي تقبلها الشعب العراقي الشقيق بكافه
اطيافه في مواجهه هذه التحديات
وما حققته الدوله العراقيه من انجازات
مهمه سامحه باسترجاع دور المؤسسات الدوله
والقضاء على مشروعات الارهاب الزلابيه
وتحقيق امن واستقرار وزياده البلاد وصوله
وحده نسيجها الوطنيه
كما لا يفوتني ان اشد بمساعد دوله
العراقيه على صعيد اطلاق مشروعات اعاده
الاعمار وتمهيد الطريق